.
TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
A FEW WEEKS AGO A DRIVER FOR A
CHARTERED BUS COMPANY REACHED
OUT TO REPORTERS AT FOX 17
NASHVILLE.
TOLD NOT TO SPEAK TO THE MEDIA,
BUT SHE DID IT ANYWAY, WHY?
WHAT SHE WAS SEEING EVERY DAY ON
THE JOB WAS SO STRANGE SO
WITHOUT PRECEDENT 20 YEAR CAREER
AS A DRIVER, THAT SHE FELT SHE
HAD TO TELL THE PUBLIC ABOUT IT.
STARTING THIS APRIL, THE BUS
DRIVER SAID, GOVERNMENT AGENTS
BEGAN INSTRUCTING HER TO PICK UP
BUSLOADS OF MIGRANT CHILDREN'S
FOREIGN NATIONALS FROM MEXICO
ET CETERA PIER THE DRIVER WASN'T
GIVING ANY INFORMATION BEYOND
THAT.
SHE WAS TOLD TO TAKE THOSE
CHILDREN DEEP INTO THE INTERIOR
OF THE UNITED STATES AWAY FROM
THE BORDER AND DO IT AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE "THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME DROP-OFFS IN ASHEVILLE,
CHATTANOOGA, COUPLE IN ATLANTA,
THE DRIVER SAID."
THAT IS AS FAR AS I WOULD GO.
THEN THE CHILDREN CONTINUE ON
FURTHER.
ANOTHER SOURCE FAMILIAR WITH
WHAT IS GOING ON GOING ON TOPOCK
17TH OF FOREIGN NATIONALS TAKE
AS FAR AWAY AS NEW YORK,
CHICAGO, MIAMI.
BUT THERE IS A PROBLEM.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO CHANGE THE
POPULATION OF A COUNTRY WITH
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE FINDING
OUT THE MAID IS TOUGH TO DO WITH
BUSES BECAUSE PACKED WITH
ILLEGAL MINORS FROM WITHOUT THE
PROPER I.D. OR BE IN THIS
COUNTRY AT ALL, PEOPLE TEND TO
NOTICE.
SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAME
UP WITH A DIFFERENT PLAN "NOW
THEY ARE FLYING THE KIDS BECAUSE
THE BUSES WERE EASIER TO
VIDEOTAPE GOING DOWN THE
HIGHWAY."
ASK YOURSELF, BY THE WAY, SINCE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT DEMOCRACY
IN THIS COUNTRY COME EVERYTHING
IS A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
IF YOU CHANGE THE POPULATION OF
THE COUNTRY WITHOUT THE CONSENT
OF THE PEOPLE LIVING THERE WITH
THAT DEMOCRACY, DOESN'T THE
COUNTRY BELONG TO THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE THERE QUESTION WORK THAT IS
WHAT DEMOCRACY IS.
WHAT A SMALL NUMBER OF DIALOGUES
TO TAKE AWAY FROM THOSE PEOPLE
AND GIVE IT TO FOREIGN
NATIONALS?
THAT WOULD NOT BE FOREIGN
DEMOCRACY.
SOME OF THE FOOTAGE HOLING
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS FROM BACK IN
MARCH AND WE HAVE A CLIP FOR
THIS.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING MOST OF THE
TIME IS THEY ARE BOARDING BUSES
AND HEADING INTO AMERICA'S
HEARTLAND.
A CONVEYOR BELT OF COMMERCIAL
AND CHARTER BUSES JUST LIKE THIS
ONE AND DEL RIO, TEXAS.
CARRYING TENS OF THOUSANDS SIGHT
UNSEEN FROM TEXAS ARIZONA AND
CALIFORNIA BORDERLANDS NORTHWARD
AND THEY ARE DROPPING THEIR
HAITIAN, VENEZUELAN, CUBAN,
CENTRAL AMERICAN FAMILY UNITS IN
FLORIDA, IN NEW JERSEY,
TENNESSEE, MASSACHUSETTS,
MICHIGAN, NORTH CAROLINA,
GEORGIA, KENTUCKY AND TWO LARGE
CITIES IN TEXAS SUCH AS DALLAS
AND HOUSTON.
>> Tucker: HOW IS THIS NOT THE
BIGGEST STORY IN THE COUNTRY?
YOU ARE CHANGING THE POPULATION
OF AMERICA WITHOUT THE CONSENT
OF AMERICANS BUT DOING IT
SECRETLY ON A HUGE SCALE AND NO
ONE IS NOTICING?
SIX MONTHS AFTER INAUGURATION
DAY, THE BORDERS ARE MORE OPEN
THAN EVER.
IT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING YOU NEED
TO KNOW ABOUT HOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION APPROACH IS
IMMIGRATION.
THEY WILL NOT STOP THE FLOW OF
MIGRANTS ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, NO.
INSTEAD, THEY GET THOSE MIGRANTS
FREED TRANSPORTATION TO ANYWHERE
IN THE UNITED STATES THEY
CHOOSE.
WHEN YOU KNOWS THEY ARE DOING IT
THEY DON'T STOP BUT FIND A
DIFFERENT WAY TO DO IT, A NEW
METHOD OF TRANSPORTATION.
HOW IS THIS NOT INVASION?
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
IT IS BEING EMBEDDED BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
HERE ARE THE NUMBERS.
IN MAY OF LAST YEAR, A TOTAL OF
24,000 PEOPLE WERE ENCOUNTERED
BY AUTHORITIES AT THAT SOUTHERN
LAND BORDER AND THIS YEAR THE
NUMBER HAD RISEN TO 180,000.
108,000 PEOPLE.
THAT IS EQUIVALENT TO THE ENTIRE
CITY OF CHATTANOOGA, TENNESSEE,
SHOWING UP THE SOUTHERN BORDER
EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
I'M NOT SURE I'M PICKING DATA
BUT LAST APRIL 17000 PEOPLE
SHOWED UP AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THIS APRIL NUMBER WAS 178,000.
IT IS THAT KIND OF INCREASE
DRAMATIC TO THE POINT THAT YOUR
EYES ARE POPPED OPEN EVERY MONTH
OF THIS YEAR SINCE JOE BIDEN
BECAME PRESIDENT.
IN ALL, THE NUMBERS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS CROSSING THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER WITH THE
HIGHEST LEVEL SINCE 2006 WITH
FOUR MONTHS STILL UNACCOUNTED.
HERE IS WHAT IT ACTUALLY LOOKS
LIKE AT THE RIO GRANDE.
>> IN LESS THAN AN HOUR, THE
SMUGGLERS HAVE BROUGHT A GROUP
OF 16 MIGRANTS INTO THE
UNITED STATES JUST IN THE SPOT
ALONE.
MANY OF THEM WOMEN AND CHILDREN.
BORDER PATROL BUSES CAN'T GET
DOWN TO THE RIVER'S EDGE SO
AGENTS HAVE TO PUT THE MIGRANTS
UP TO A PROCESS AREA AND THAT IS
WHERE THEY ARE JOINED BY OTHER
MIGRANTS ILLEGALLY CROSSED IN
THE AREA.
IT IS BIG BUSINESS FOR THE HUGE
SMUGGLERS TO BENEFIT THE MOST
FROM THE ONGOING BORDER CRISIS.
>> Tucker: SO THAT REPORT
MAKES AN IMPORTANT POINT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING OVER
ECONOMIC MIGRANTS FROM POOR
COUNTRIES TO ALERT JUST WELFARE
STATE IN THE WORLD WHICH IS OUR
COUNTRY.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY BE?
THEY WOULD DO THE SAME IF THEY
COULD APPEAR TO BE SHOULDN'T
ALLOW THEM BUT YOU CAN'T BLAME
HIM FOR WANTING TO.
BUT NOT ALL OF THEM ARE GOOD
PEOPLE WITH OBVIOUS HUMAN
MOTIVES LIKE US.
SOME WERE VERY BAD PEOPLE.
SOME OF THEM HAVE PRE-EXISTING
CRIMINAL RECORDS.
ACCORDING TO CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES HAVE ARRESTED 760
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS SINCE OCTOBER
ON THE TEXAS BORDER.
LAST YEAR DURING THE SAME
PERIOD, THEY ARRESTED 60 PEOPLE.
SO I THINK 900% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
DETAINED WITH CRIMINAL
BACKGROUNDS.
BY THE WAY, THAT IS NOT ALL THAT
CAME HERE BUT THOSE ARE THE ONES
WE DETAINED.
WE SHOULD TELL YOU THAT INCLUDE
SEX OFFENDERS AND GANG MEMBERS.
NOT JUST DRUG TRAFFICKERS AND A
LOT OF DRUG TRAFFICKERS.
IN THE MIDDLE OF A DRUG WAR
RIGHT NOW, EVERYONE.
ACCORDING TO TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
SAFETY JUST IN THE LAST YEAR,
FOR INTERNAL SEIZURES AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER HAVE SEARCH 800%
IN TEXAS BUT KEEP IN MIND
FENTANYL IS EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
TO DETECT AND DOESN'T TAKE MUCH
BUT ODORLESS AND COLORLESS AND Y
EASY TO SMUGGLE FENTANYL AND
IT'S EASY TO DO.
THE O.D. RATES IN THE
UNITED STATES OFF OF THE CHARTS
AND THOSE DEATHS ARE BEING WITH
THE DRUG TRADE ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT IS KILLING AMERICANS.
SO THIS IS A DISASTER AND FOR
NUMBERS PROVE IT BUT ACCORDING
TO KAMALA HARRIS, IT IS
PROGRESS.
>> TO THE MEN AND WOMEN ON THE
GROUND EVERY DAY, I COMMEND ALL
OF THEM WHO THEY HAVE SEEN SO
FAR, THEY CALL IT PROGRESS.
WE ARE NOT EXACTLY WHERE WE WANT
TO BE YET, BUT EXTREME PROGRESS
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
>> Tucker: EXTREME PROGRESS.
AS THE NUMBERS RISE AND AS THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WITHOUT
YOUR PERMISSION OR KNOWLEDGE BUT
AT YOUR EXPENSE MOVE SOME
UNKNOWN THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE INTO
THE INTERIOR OF THE
UNITED STATES WITH NEW LIVES,
AGAIN OF FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
NOT A SLAM ON THEM PUT AN ATTACK
AND WE SHOULD ALL JOIN ON THE
PEOPLE MAKING IT POSSIBLE WITH
QUESTIONS WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT
IT?
THERE IS NO OVERSIGHT AT ALL
FROM CONGRESS.
CERTAINLY NOT FROM THE MEDIA.
THE STAKES COULD NOT BE HIGHER.
AT THIS POINT, THERE WAS ONLY
ONE WAY TO STOP IT.
THERE IS ONLY ONE MAN WHO CAN IN
HIS NAME IS GREG ABBOTT, THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS CAN SEND
THE NATIONAL GUARD TO THE BORDER
AND SEAL IT.
IT IS HIS BORDER TOO.
19,000 SOLDIERS IN THE TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD.
AS OF TONIGHT, WE BELIEVE
GREG ABBOTT HAS DEPLOYED 500 OF
THEM TO THE BORDER.
WHY IS THAT?
WHY NOT SEAL THE BORDER BETWEEN
TEXAS AND MEXICO?
CALIFORNIA WILL NOT DO IT, IT
WAS MAY OR MAY NOT.
WHY AREN'T THEY?
WE WANTED TO ASK GREG ABBOTT
THAT QUESTION BUT HE REFUSED TO
COME ON.
WHEN THE SENIOR OFFICIAL IN THE
STATE OF TEXAS WE WILL TALK TO
HIM IN A MINUTE.
WE WANT TO BEGIN WITH SOMEONE
WHO IS DOWN THERE FIRSTHAND
SEEING WHAT IS HAPPENING.
ONE OF THE FEW REPORTERS WHO HAS
COVERED THE OPEN BORDERS.
THAT IS -- LAST NIGHT HE WAS IN
ROME AT TEXAS AND A COYOTE
SHOWED UP ACROSS THE RIVER IN A
RAFT.
>> WE ARE HERE IN ROME AT TEXAS
AND THE RIO GRANDE IS BEHIND ME.
AND COYOTES THEY WERE BRINGING
OVER ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS RIGHT
HERE IN THIS SPOT COME A VERY
POPULAR CROSSING AREA.
THERE WAS NO BORDER PATROL.
NO HIGHWAY PATROL